Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Am 2. August 1964.
Ich bin 1,80 m groß.
Ungefähr 95 kg.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Müller?
Ich habe seit mehr als 5 Tagen Schmerzen im Bauch.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Im Unterbauch.
Rechte oder saubende oder mittel?
Die sind eher unten, eher linksseitig.
Wie ist die Strandschmerz in der Köpfe-Region?
Ich leiste ein bisschen.
Wobei sind die aufgetreten?
Ich weiß nicht.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Frau Seider.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
19, 53, 19, 72.
Am 25. Februar.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,65 m.
Mein Gewicht ist ca. 70 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausast?
Das ist die Franziska Müller.
Frau Hanke, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Geboren bin ich am 21. Mai 1968.
Frau Hanke, wie groß sind Sie?
1,61 m.
Kennen Sie Ihr Aktuellengewicht?
Ja, so 82 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1943.
1. Mai 1963.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ca. 1,83 m.
Wie groß sind Sie?
90 kg.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bauarbeiter.
Darf ich Ihre Familienfragen?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. April 1969.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,73 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie Society?
Ich wiege ca. 100 kg.
Entschlugung?
Erzählen Sie, Herr Brandt,
warum führen Sie den Verhältnis?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht, was es ist,
aber ich habe seit drei Tagen starke Schmerzen auf der Brust.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl,
mir sitzt ein großer Elefant auf der Brust.
Ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Es wird von Tag zu Tag immer schlimmer.
Können Sie mir sagen,
wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kühler?
Ich bin 58.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 8. Mai 1965.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 87 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Am 12. November 1985.
Wie viel wiegen Sie dazeit?
Ich wiege 65 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Vielen Dank, Frau Westermann.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Frau Bandt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin der 16 Jahre alt.
Am 18. Februar 1958.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie dazeit?
Muss ich Ihnen das verraten?
Ich bin 56.
Wie wiegen Sie dazeit?
Muss ich Ihnen das verraten?
Ja, es wäre toll.
Wie wiegen Sie dazeit?
Ich habe 84 kg.
84 kg.
Okay, gut.
Frau Bandt,
was bringst du zu uns?
Ich habe heute eine Küche sauber gemacht.
Ich habe eine schwere Sprudelkiste.
Ich habe eine Schwere sauber gemacht.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen in der Brust.
Das strahlt in den ganzen Arm.
Das strahlte in den ganzen Arm.
Das war wirklich schlecht,
weil ich mich ein bisschen hingesetzt habe.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Düpfer?
Noch bin ich 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt?
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Dritten 64.
64, okay.
Ich werde in einem Monat, 1,5 Monaten,
werde ich einigen.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 m.
Wie viel wiegt ihr zur Zeit?
Bestimmt 70 kg.
70 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Kübler.
Frau Düpfer,
wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Oktober 1967.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,66 m.
Und ich wiege 78 kg.
78 kg.
Und Sie sind 1,66 m.
Groß und alt.
Und ich wiege 78 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
45 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 22. Juni 1979 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 1,80 m groß und wiege
circa 90 kg.
Sie sind 180 cm groß
und Sie wiegen 90 kg.
Und Bach ist auch ganz kurz.
B, A, C, H.
Herr Bach, wie alt sind Sie
geboren?
Ich bin noch 51 Jahre alt.
51. Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 18.4. 1974.
18.4. 1900.
1974.
1974. Wie groß sind Sie
und wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Bach?
Ich bin 1,81 m
und wiege so um die 75 kg.
75 kg?
75 kg. Nicht 70 kg, 75 kg.
75 kg. Okay.